With California facing a megadrought, many
fear that fire season this year will be bigger
and more devastating than previous years.
But is there a way we could fight forest fires,
with fire?
Hey guys Julia here for Dnews
With drought drying up the west, the threat
of wildfires is more dire than ever.
In the past five years, many states have seen
the biggest fires in 50 years.
Previous wildfires have caused millions of
dollars in damage to homes and property.
Some fires even were deadly.
So it’s no wonder the US Government spends
billions every year to fight them.
But unfortunately it’s not a simple case
as some bear in a hat wants us to believe.
Historically, places like California saw big
burns every year.
But as more and more people moved west, forest
fires had to be stopped.
But decades of fighting forest fires actually
made things worse for a little while.
It made some ecosystems less diverse.
And suppressing natural fires led to a buildup
of debris and clutter on the forest floor,
setting the stage for disasters to come.
After the Yellowstone fires of 1988 and the
fire season of 2000, people began to understand
that some ecosystems NEED fire, they’ve
evolved to make use of it.
Fire is part of their natural lifecycle.
Fire benefits an ecosystem in a few ways.
Sometimes it breaks down nutrients in a flash,
literally.
Nutrients from leaves, logs, and other debris
that otherwise would have taken years or decades
to break down and return to the soil.
Some plants actually need fire and heat to
thrive.
Like the giant sequoias in Sierra Nevada region
in California.
They need the heat of fire to reproduce!
Sequoias make large cones, that only open
and disperse their seeds when they dry up.
One of the primary ways they dry out, is from,
you guess it kids, the heat of a fire.
And they aren’t the only ones.
In the Pinelands in new jersey, there’s
several species that need fire to reproduce
including the pygmy pitch pine.
This small plant evolved a few ways to fight
fire.
It’s got thick bark that protects it from
the heat.
But if the trunk happens to be damaged by
fire, it can regrow sprouts from the wound!
Fire doesn’t just help things grow, sometimes
its powers of destruction, are for good!
By clearing out clutter, it can destroy invasive
species or harmful insects and can even open
up the dense forest canopy to allow sunlight
to reach the forest floor, so more things
can grow.
It also creates new areas of grasslands which
some species of animals depend on for shelter
or food.
so what do we do? is there a way we can protect
our homes while still allowing these delicate
ecosystems to thrive?
Well every year some forestry services practice
what’s called controlled burn or prescribed
fireY.
yes there are people whose job it is to set
fires.
ON PURPOSE.
But it’s a tricky business.
The conditions have to be just right or a
fire could quickly get out of control.
If conditions are too dry, the fire can get
too hot or too big too quickly, and there
are a few cases of controlled burns getting
out of control.
If too damp, well nothing’s going to burn.
In the Pinelands of New Jersey parameters
for burning are tight, like under 55 degrees,
wind speeds of 7 to 12 miles per hour and
about two or three days since the last rainfall.
In some years, they can burn up to 22,000
acres of forest.
And this policy seems to be helping.
One study published in the journal Ecosphere,
found that areas that were purposely burned
had twice as many native plant species as
nonburned areas after 10 years.
And other studies from the Ecological Society
of America show that prescribed burns reduce
the severity of wildfires.
But these are small, very well managed, controlled
burns.
So it seems it really pays to fight fire with
fire.
But only if you’re a professional with a
permit, so still listen to that bear in a
hat.